I think he's just a step or two ahead of  where everyone else is right he's just  yeah he's got the the charisma and the  sense of humor and definitely the crowd  he going for him but I think he's just  super smart as well and yeah I think  that's where he would you say Gary Busey  farting on you okay I got something for  you which is a natural bodily function  and children all do animals fa fa re  stands for feeling a rectal transmission  Oh  see ya know don't you know that you get  on elevator and letter let out a fart  and then ask everybody play name that  smell and you'll be very popular  it really doesn't justify your behavior  no it just allowed gasser you just you  know what that